[Music]
every hero has a storyline
that defines them sometimes it's a
fateful event
that turns an ordinary person into a
legend
and tongfu is going to continue to push
they're not done mech
still hasn't even been used there's a
hook how
brought all the way back to the base
cleaned up by the fountain or maybe it's
through their determination
to overcome heartbreaking adversity i
came into this tournament with my father
yeah he passed away just before i got
here and his last wish was that i
i went here and so i really want to
dedicate
this win to my father and occasionally
it's from defiantly staring
insurmountable odds in the face and
triumphing
in spite of them as cloud9 sets the push
up oh
oh this happens they made it work
clown nine are your a league major
champions
whatever form these moments take one
thing is for certain
they don't present themselves that often
but when they do
if they're seized they're capable of
changing lives forever
[Music]
now for most people these unforgettable
landmark moments are fleeting they
simply can't be savored long enough
but in the strange case of owen od pixel
davies
he couldn't wait for his moment to be
over
just piece of fight bkb
he's eggnog so low he's gonna go down
that's a kill oh no
static stomp onto both seven and cut the
punches
there's the side he's dead as well two
heroes down and oh
no no it's not the music we're reset
right okay so
how exactly did one of dota's all-time
longest
and strangest matches launch the career
of one of its most celebrated casters
and what can be learned from his
tortured hilarious experience
do we get a bathroom breaker i mean mate
if you need to go and relieve
yourself i'm just kidding
okay so if you're not familiar with dota
2's resident
rap god here's what you need to know
when he's not being a
model professional you're likely to find
this proper dota lad
forging new friendships in pubs try to
join me son
do you want to [ __ ] draw me i'm going
to punch you
yeah thank you for the jaw damage you
stupid [ __ ] nice old mate you want to
just die
you want to go where your mom is to hell
with a big [ __ ] in her face
thank you and when he's not doing that
you might catch him trying to master new
languages
struggling with spicy cuisine oh no my
tears
they're hot as well
ow and it's going beyond
or flexing his knack for romantic banter
on stream oh wow what is it i mean that
does look like a dinosaur
not gonna lie looks like you in the
morning
damn thank you sweet nothings aside
as a caster od pixel's reputation was
built on his very specific skill set
you see he's a bit of a fast talker they
know that the
side of border on the high ground
miracle's gonna jump forward straight
away the vkb comes out he'll throw the
aoe japanese glass pulls himself down to
the bottom saxophone comes up with a
burst right here
he catches two he's also proven himself
capable of hitting notes
that no grown man ever should oh my god
but alongside his occasionally
pre-pubescent machine gun-like delivery
is a talent for reading the game and
reacting to it with
razor sharp wit one that has produced
some of dota's
funniest and most authentic casting
moments
envy he's on a cliff he's on a cliff
oh i don't think he's got past the clip
everybody's just sitting there watching
them all
they don't know he's up there and
are they are they gonna work no they
think he's gone oh i'm old
envy what what are you doing
od pixel loves dota i mean genuinely
obsessed
there are casters who force themselves
to like the game you know to stay
employed but owen's passion is organic
and you can feel it in his casts
his reactions are fan like he goes
absolutely mental
sometimes doesn't even make sense but
it's raw unfiltered passion that the
fans love
and if there's a low point in the game
owen is creative enough to fill it with
something memorable so
how did this veritable speed demon end
up with the responsibility of casting
some of dota's
most important matches well odi pixel's
road to the international actually
started like most dota players careers
from the comfort of his own bedroom i
didn't really have the the kind of the
balls the guts to do on my own so i was
talking to my mate and i was like hey
joanna
do you want to try casting out together
so we started doing it as kind of a
pairing thing
that we both live very close to each
other so we had the ability to kind of
set up you know a very kind of
rough studio in my bedroom where we
could come around and it could be a bit
of fun
i think it is actually if you think
about it it's quite indie in the
beginning and it was just a breath of
fresh air really
as casting was just getting way too
corporate and stiff
he was the people's champion i'd say a
twitch meme and i don't want to sound
biased but i think the british accent
clearly didn't hurt
reggae on the gyrocopter seal kid he's
on the witch doctor over on the side of
the dyer
we've got identity next no esther back
on the leaner
while od's trademark brain breaking
delivery
often resembles a sprint
up top top his big
break was actually more like a marathon
after casting a few small games for
beyond the summit
odie was offered a gig on the main
channel and understandably
he was beyond excited they said do you
want to cast this game cloud9
versus scary faces and then they were
like by the way your codecasters purge
and at the time i was like purge that's
pretty legit this man's like a big name
he's the guy that i watch the videos of
and
they're gonna put him casting with me so
i was kind of like okay i gotta keep it
cool gotta keep it cool however what
started off as a fairly routine cast in
an ordinary series
turns out to be anything but that during
its
comically grueling second game is it
gonna be a 100 minute game i
if you go 94 minutes in it kind of has
to it's a bit of a letdown if we don't
reach the 100 mark come on
he's dead yet again 96 seconds that's
your clockwork dead assassinate you got
pete mate
but there is the aegis on the rubik he's
gonna come back for round two but round
two
it's not gonna be a pretty one misery he
melts in a few seconds
c9 they lose three heroes again but but
they've all got buybacks sir
uh we're probably going to be here for
another 10 minutes so purge what were
you gonna were you gonna do anything
with your day today
or well not anymore it's gone the whole
day
my time is spent watching people buy
back if something fun and clown is
happening you gotta be fun and clowny
yourself
no one wants to see here you kind of sit
there be serious at all around three
hours into the game
oh he's got himself a night fighter it's
boring so you've just got to make it
entertaining
and especially singing as my first kind
of break i was like i've got to do
something here that's that's going to
make people talk about this i've got to
go around this the right way
now as minutes turned into hours odi
started to realize that his sanity
wasn't the only thing being tested oh
can you see that midge
look at that look at that look at this
what is this i can't see that look at
mid lane
oh this is burning look oh look he's on
fire
what is going on their feet are on fire
it's almost on fire
[Music]
i've i've heard of this happening when
the games get this late
there's so much there's actually so much
at the time i was kind of panicking you
know it was my first kind of big kind of
exposure and i was like
people are gonna be watching this and
because it's three hours long they're
gonna kind of point out my flaws you
know you're three hours into a cast
you're not going to be the your best
ability so i'm like this is the first
time 90 000 people have seen me
i've got to kind of nail it three two
one a hundred minutes we
did it then it goes in
oh here we go seven he's
big daddy he's a big pig questa cleaning
up that's the earthshaker zeus down
but buy back in 10 seconds could they do
anything to find rape as a drop no we're
back okay reset
reset i don't think my heart can take
much more this
there's your hook shot yes straight in
onto the fight onto in chart here we go
but they bring it down both seven so
quick he's dead they're going for the
hatred can't they do it
no anti-mage is dead they're all dying
triple kill they're trying to hit
it
no we can't they're all dead but finally
after exactly
three hours 20 minutes and 34 seconds
sweet relief arrived for both od pixel
and purge
oh no this could be it this could be it
quista
is going for the p4 there's even a blade
fanta could he do it could he stop it
big daddy
women's defy rapier the damage is enough
bristle backs down disrupter trying to
tp how he gets away
they're trying to chase down the rest
but bristle back he flies back
it keeps back into the fight they're
gonna go for the tier fours
they're on the ages there isn't any
fortification
it's gonna be gg sfc they win
they'll win the game oh my god having
made it through a match that was so long
it nearly broke
the game od was rewarded with the one
thing he wanted most
recognition this was his moment this is
when he showed the world just how good
he was
and the week before he'd been casting to
50 viewers now he was casting to 80
000 that's an incredible amount of
pressure for a new caster
but full credit to owen because he took
it in his stride what odi
wasn't expecting though were the
comparisons between his casting
and a certain fast-talking rapper try to
fight up against g
but g pops the cheese now he's going to
hit against the pig who's got back to
base
i think this is mega creams and lysander
i think this is gg well played
but i i guess it's not a bad comparison
i mean he's a successful guy so people
want to compare me to eminem
all right let's go with me not long
after his epic cast
od was offered a chance to work with
dream league an
opportunity that allowed him to quit his
job at a local pharmacy
relocate to sweden and fully commit to
dota
od's career was rapidly on the rise he
was now getting to travel around the
world
doing exactly what he loved most casting
dota you when you're actually doing when
you're actually going
and thanks to his uncanny ability to
keep up with the action at
breakneck speeds it wasn't long before
fans started asking for him to appear at
the international
and when august 2015 rolled around he
got his chance
well look at the base kp what's he going
to do next he could go for the bottom
set
look for megas there's gonna be arkon
they're looking to finish the game here
they're going for
the finish qo's back he buys back he
pops the bkb he's gonna be very careful
about losing his life here this is an
incredibly tense part of the game mss
getting low they're taking down one tier
four they're looking for the second but
at the same time the damage from kp he's
going for the second tier four here in
the mid lane
the buyback comes out from trust though
he's gonna look for the defense maybe
look to stop
kp he needs to stop this anti-base but
kp just continues
on the other side the front exposed as
well they're gonna pull the guardian age
you'll continue to hit it
but he's been hexed up he can't get the
damage out of the throne
he's going to kill himself and he needs
to get himself back to base it could be
his suicide
bomb back guys for the storm spread he's
going to kill him he's getting arc on
the hell out of their base buy back from
gyrocopter as well
because they need to defend their own
fountain oh what the hell is going on
from that point on od pixel became a
regular fixture among dota's a-list
commentators
and as his reputation grew so too did
his catalogue of
classic sound bites that person just
disappeared that was less of a bear more
for winnie the pooh
he got absolutely shredded and np
they'll try their best
oh what the [ __ ]
envy he sees an opportunity he's
immediately on to the test the swap will
be there separating the channels
oh vp it's absolutely mother trucking
beautiful the buyback's there for the
task
other than the golden just chasing them
down the mp making sure the smell was
about to get gh
and with the three-man echo slab once
again
sending three of eg straight to their
grave the community perception frody
pixels almost unanimously
extremely positive i would say that if i
would analyze his brain he has
very very very few negative or fans or
haters i think almost everybody
uh likes od pixel now as much as od had
achieved in his relatively short
career there was still one goal his eyes
were firmly set on
casting a ti grand final and at ti-8 in
vancouver he
finally got his shot at doing just that
once again od pixel was given a chance
to shine
and once more he rose to the occasion
reading down and on the side thompson
jumps in chalice gets him to be coming
into the call
sep he's got the disabled challenge do
they have the damage they've gone out
there with the chalice he's into the
snowball if fly buying time for him
straight back into the game anna trying
to find his attention onto x and over
chalice leading forward the tornado
gonna be off the market only catches out
the blood sigma step he's looking for
the following jumps in
gets the call the bkb was only turned
the bananas on something didn't even
know it set for the playback f1
with the snowball again thompson jacks
focusing the racks thompson gets the
hecks up onto x number seven healed up
by jarrett
and are still full health at the moment
as the brewings are pushed back to the
base oh gee
get the bottom mainly racks but they're
fully low ogd
that solders them for two minutes they
get thompson thompson never do but it's
only anna
anna can you do it here he's at our bell
shack
[Applause]
they have done it i've done it
the power of flowers and friendship
i've done it here ladies and gentlemen
your grand
champions
it's o g four years earlier od pixel had
been casting for
fun from his own bedroom but now he had
provided commentary to arguably
the greatest best of five series in
dota's history
on its absolute biggest stage and off
the back of
rave reviews for his performance he was
able to do it all over again
in 2019 i can't believe what we're
seeing in this game for
oh gee
[Applause]
see that's what's truly endeared od
pixel to fans over the years
the fact that he never lost sight of who
he was
that in spite of his growing fame and
achievements he never took himself too
seriously and he never stopped being one
of them
stop playing random card
games i don't care how much money you
get from the developer
and even though there probably won't be
a ti this year od pixel continues to
prove that he's a star
capable of shining on a stage of any
size
and just because he's been temporarily
relegated back to the confines of his
bedroom
no one is going to be forgetting the
mark he's left on the game anytime soon
i'd like to think that people can see
the journey that i've taken
and it can show them that it's totally
possible to do od pixel's rise is
very well deserved is the best way to
describe it like that's why he
was so why he went so viral in the
moment because um he's just he's
basically perfect for the job
he's very quick-witted he's a very smart
guy
and his brain works very fast too so
he's always ready to keep up with the
pace of a fast-paced dota game so
as long as he can dive in and fully
immerse himself in a game that he's
going to do excellent
you see od pixel is the perfect example
of someone
seizing their opportunity when it
presents itself he's proof that in
esports you can become a star through
passion and hard work
and more importantly you can do it while
staying true to your own
unique identity even if that identity
is a little out of the ordinary there's
no such thing as
mistakes just just happy little
accidents
as a british light the uh spicy yeah i
was gonna say
you identify with him on a spiritual
level
more like a big box when i watched that
video it made me tear almost
oh no my tears they're hot as well
those wings look pretty hot